[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
RV Marseille bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sénateur des hautes
scènes président du groupe Union
centriste au Sénat et président de l'UDI
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représenté par Julien
l'écuer de la voie du Nord bonjour
Julien bonjour Orian bonjour monsieur
Marseille bonjour sans surprise parler
de la loi immigration RV Marseille lundi
aura donc lieu la commission mixte
paritaire qui réunit députés et
sénateurs pour tenter de trouver un
accord est-ce que lundi c'est trop tôt
est-ce que la conclusion d'un accord est
possible dans ce
délai Sénat avait exprimé une voix
différente puisque quand on a appris que
le choix de l'exécutif c'était d'aller
vers une commission mixte paritaire on
en a pris acte et nous on souhaitait
prendre du temps c'est un texte qui euh
qui est là sur la table depuis le mois
de de février on en parle quasiment
depuis un an pouvait prendre 5 minutes
de plus euh pour apaiser et puis essayer
de rapprocher les points de vue discuter
profiter des des fêtes de fin d'année
pour rechercher des convergences bon le
choix a été différent c'est celui de
réunir rapidement euh la commission
mixte paritaire au il aurait été mieux
d'attendre janvier pour vous bah oui
maintenant bon c'est comme ça on fait
avec quelles peuvent être les
conséquences de cette urgence là de de
négocier aussi rapidement bah euh c'est
fait un peu dans la
précipitation sur le thème ça sert à
rien d'attendre s'il a un accord on peut
le faire tout de suite sinon qu'est-ce
qui se passera de différent dans un mois
pour ça peut braquer les gens mais pour
vous c'est une erreur bah c'est-à-dire
que ça amoindr les chances de trouver un
accord ce délai raccourci en tous les
cas c'est c'est pas facile de rapprocher
des points de vuees qui sont quand même
assez éloignés en quelques heures
maintenant il y a un texte celui du
Sénat et il faut voir quelles sont les
concessions qu' nous sommes capables
d'accepter pour essayer de trouver un
accord justement justement vous avez
rencontré la première ministre
ellisabeth B hier qu'est-il ressorti de
cette réunion euh d'abord qu'elle est
engagée qu'elle est impliquée qu'elle
cherche l'accord puisque c'est sa
mission
euh nous nous avons un texte qui est
celui du du Sénat entre parenthèses
heureusement là encore qu'il y a un
texte au Sénat et je vois qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde dit le texte du Sénat
merveilleux formidable moi je me
souviens de ce qui s'est passé il y a
quelques semaines vous aussi
certainement il a fallu bagarrer pour
qu'il y ait un texte hein euh de la même
façon au moment des retraites
heureusement qu'il y avait le texte du
Sénat donc une fois de plus le Sénat a
montré euh qu'il était euh indispensable
dans le fonctionnement des institutions
surtout avec la configuration de
l'Assemblée nationale donc on peut
trouver un accord on a regardé les point
euh difficile laame par exemple euh
amuainéé voilà l'aide médicale
ça peut faire l'objet d'un texte séparé
en début d'année donc ça ça pourrait
être le compromis on le sort du le
projet de immigration et on fait une
réforme à part en début d'année
proochaine un des éléments du compromis
si un engagement du gouvernement pour
dire que c'est parce que c'est vrai
qu'on parle de cavalier législatif
c'estàdire de de textes qui n'ont pas
leur place dans le texte immigration on
pourrait considérer qu'il y a un débat à
accepter mais c'est pas le seul un texte
qui pourrait être partie du texte qui
pourrait être considéré comme un
cavalier législatif on parle aussi du
code de la nationalité ou encore les
prestations sociales aux étrangers voà
il y a un certain nombre de points qu'on
va considérer comme irritant pour
l'Assemblée nationale et où nous sommes
disposés pour ce qui est de la majorité
sénatoriale à discuter de ces ces
différents points pour essayer de tendre
la main à nos collègues de l'Assemblée
parce que ouis non juste juste pour
compléter la question Julien parce que
hier soir il y a des réunions évidemment
partout hein hier soir les députés
Renaissance se sont réunis ils ont acté
trois lignes rouges le retrait de la
réforme de la me vous nous en avez parlé
la suppression de l'article qui
conditionne le bénéfice de certaines
prestations sociales à 5 années de
résidence en France et la fin de la
restriction de l'accès à la nationalité
est-ce que des compromis sont possibles
sur ces trois points quand on veut on
peut oui c'est possible oui c'est
possible vous vous y êtes favorable mais
est-ce que est-ce que la droite les
républicains sont prêts à le faire à
l'impossible nul n'est tenu vous en avez
parlé avec
oui qui qui dit quoi est-ce que vous
êtes sur la même nous nous sommes nous
sommes désireux de trouver un un un
chemin qui mène au compromis parce que
le problème c'est pas de savoir si les
républicains les renaissances ou je ne
sais qui sont d'accord le problème c'est
de savoir si on est capable d'apporter
des réponses aux Français les gens ils
nous regardent leur problème c'est pas
de savoir à quelle heure on se réunit
avec qui le problème c'est de dire il y
a des il y a des problè il y a des
difficultés concernant les problèmes
migratoires c'est des problèmes que
rencontrre l'ensemble des pays européens
on voit les
ravages que ça amène en terme politique
la montée du populisme on a vu encore
récemment en Hollande donc notre
problème c'est de dire il y a un sujet
migratoire important qui tarud de la
société française il faut apporter des
réponse on peut le faire bon les lignes
apportées par la majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale sont des lignes dépassables on
peut arriver à des compromis il faut que
chacun fasse des pas bon il se trouve
que l'assemblée a échoué à trouvver un
accord c'est sur la base du texte du
Sénat que devra se faire l'accord je
comprends que ça satisfacee pas tous les
députés mais on peut
trouver des chemins pour pour aboutir
l'indice on s'y emploie et moi je suis
assez optimiste mais alors si si on dit
justement que ces lignes rouges lign
rouges tracé par par le groupe
Renaissance sont modifiables qu'on peut
qu'on peut trouver un compromis
là-dessus finalement où se situe le nœud
du problème c'est encore la
régularisation dans les métiers en
tenstion
non je pense qu'il y a un certain nombre
de de députés chez Renaissance mais
aussi chez mes amis du modem ou chez
Liot qui sont interrogés par les les
évolutions parce que le texte sera
forcément plus à droite que celui qui
est sorti de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée voilà bon à un moment donné
il faudra choisir hein c'est pour ça que
c'est pas nous qui avons choisi la date
de lundi ça sera à prendre ou à laisser
bon mais sur les les travailleurs dans
les métier en tenstion est-ce qu'il est
quasi acté que c'est l'article la
version du Sénat qui sera retenue et le
fameux article 4 bis ah ça s un un
article auquel nous nous tenons tout
particulièrement et et surtout nous au
groupe Union centriste c'est un peu la
marque qu'on a réussi à imprimer au
Sénat c'est l'article 4 bis bon
euh mais ça fait plus partie des lignons
rouges des députés renaissances est-ce
que vous en avez parlé de cet article
avec Elisabeth borne est-ce que du coup
il est acté que il vous suivront rien
d'acté il y a simplement on en a parlé
et ça fait partie des choses que nous
nous nous considérons comme étant non
discutable d'ailleurs maintenant c'est
même l'ensemble de la majorité
sénatoriale qui dit voilà le Sénat a
trouvé ce compromis sur la
régularisation bon la régularisation par
les
préfets
pardon avec quelques critères dans la
loi il y a pas de quoi écrire à la
famille quand même hein et
donc
franchement
voilà je veux dire tout notre rapporteur
Philippe bonc a fait une étude sur
toutes les révisions euh qu'il a eu euh
depuis la fin de la dernière guerre sur
ce sujet si vous regardez il y a eu euh
un certain nombre de révisions euh de
réformes euh dès
1956 71 et en 81 par François mitteran
et un peu plus tard à chaque fois c'est
l'autorité de l'État c'est le
représentant de l'État le préfet quel
que soit le gouvernement de droite ou de
gauche qui a été chargé euh d'assurer
les régularisations donc dans la
continuité de l'action de l'État et de
la République on propose que ce soit les
préfets qui assurent la régularisation
avec des critères bon le souci étant que
au sein même des des des des
républicains de quand ça s'affronte et
dont l'un à l'Assemblée nationale
considère que même cette cet article 4
bis réécrit ne suffit pas créer un appel
d'air et donc compte s'y opposer ma
science politique s'arrête aux portes du
groupe à l'Assemblée national vous me
permettrez de de pas m'emmêler j'ai vu
que monsieur Pradier euh qui s'exprime
toujours avec sobriété a dit que c'était
un texte sans triste dans sa bouche ça
doit pas être un compliment mais euh bon
ma fois il devra peut-être s'en
contenter hein dans le Lot ça suffit
mais Bruno retaillot vous a dit que il
était sur votre ligne sur l'article 4
oui absolument c'est plus
sérieux mais ça ne suffira peut-être pas
à convaincre orien pradiier en effet il
y a il y a un autre une autre question
qui se pose c'est que euh visiblement
donc il pourrait y avoir un accord sur
une partie du du texte ellisabeth borne
a proposé un un saucissonnage entre
entre guillemets pour essayer justement
d'avancer vous êtes vous êtes
farouchement opposé à cette démarche
farouchement euh c'est peut-être pas euh
TER
exact simplement simplement euh ça a
déjà été évoqué au printemps CER et la
réponse avait déjà été apporté par le
président du Sénat c'est lui qui a
employé le mot de saucissonnage c'est
une expression charcutière qui qui lu
qui l'apprécie et donc euh c'était de
dire non il y a une politique migratoire
elle peut pas être présenté euh par euh
par tranche par morceau donc euh la
réponse a déjà été apportée nous ne
souhaitons pas euh que le le texte soit
tronçonné il y a un texte global et euh
la réponse du Sénat c'est NON au
saucissonnage oui un texte global euh et
un accord global à partir du texte du
Sénat HM ce matin dans Le Figaro Bruno
Le Maire appelle la majorité à
reconnaître qu'elle a subi une défaite
et à reprendre la version du Sénat en
espérant je le cite que LR comprennent
qu'il faut bouger les lignes sur deux
points sensibles pour notre majorité la
me et les conditions d'accès aux aides
social est-ce que cette déclaration de
Bruno le ma c'est un soutien de poids
pour vous en tous les cas ça va dans le
bon sens hein on devrait plus souvent
écouter Bruno le ma et donc je pense que
il dit ce que dit d'ailleurs Gérald
armanin après lui
et c'est la réalité à partir du moment
où il y a eu cette motion de rejet à
l'Assemblée nationale le texte revient
en CMP et sur la base du dernier texte
voté c'està-dire celui du Sénat donc
c'est à partir du texte du Sénat dans
son entièreté que se fait l'accord ou
pas
h on parlait de Gérald armanin il a subi
les foudres de de certains cadres de des
républicains notamment éic cioti qui
préférait qui a dit qu'il préférait même
négocier avec Elisabeth borne euh
comment vous jugez ce ce ce comportement
est-ce que c'est ce qu'il faut aller
au-delà des des accusations à nominer
mais puis surtout se poser la question
de savoir si Géral dermanin pour vous il
a commis des erreurs dans la
négociation écoutez il y a un résultat
il est ce qu'il est il faut le prendre
comme il est euh moi je j'ai travaillé
et je continue de travailler avec Gérald
armanin j'ai des relations amicales avec
lui depuis longtemps avant même qu'il
rentre au gouvernement euh je pense
qu'il s'est beaucoup coup impliqué dans
dans ce texte bon la configuration de
l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas facile
bon il y a certainement eu des choix qui
ont été faits qui ont pas qui n'ont pas
été les bons il n'a pas réussi il a
commis des erreurs politiques j'en sais
rien et en tous les cas il a pas réussi
à rassemblé le résultat il est là bon et
donc maintenant on est sur une
commission mixte paritaire l'essentiel
encore une fois c'est de trouver une
solution pour qu'il ait un texte parce
que personne ne comprendrait que après
un an de débat sur tous les sujets on
n'arrive pas dans ce pays à trouver une
solution sur un texte majeur ou alors
c'est que vraiment je veux dire on peut
comprendre que l'opposition de gauche
soit hostile elle est sur une radicalité
différente mais très sincèrement sur
l'essentiel on doit pouvoir rassembler
et trouver une solution et les
républicains pour une partie en tout cas
d'entre eux sont dans une posture de
radicalité vous le
regrettez écoutez moi je je sais pas qui
fait quoi la Assemblée nationale moi je
travaille dans la majorité sénatoriale
je me permets pas de de mimisser dans
les problèmes de de l'Assemblée enfin
j'aimerais savoir qui fait quoi parce
que quand on dit les républicain moi je
sais pas si on parle d'éicotti d'Olivier
tient pas son
parti quand même des cadres il y a quand
même Olivier marlex président de groupe
Éric président des républ va falloir
écrire unè pour savoir comment
travailler avec les républicains à
l'Assemblée j' donc ça veut dire qu'ave
ce tient pas son parti moi je travaille
dans la majorité sénatoriale sous
l'autorité du président l'archer avec
Bruno retaillot après ailleurs chaque
jour suffit sa peine François patria n
disait il était à votre place il nous
disait que si la CMP échoue le texte
sera retiré est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça ou est-ce qu'en cas
d'échec vous dites mais il faut qu'on se
remette au travail et il faut qu'on
reparte dans un débat et qu'on fasse un
encore une fois nous on travaille à ce
qu' est un résultat lundi je ne me place
pas dans une autre perspective après si
l'exécutif souhaite retirer le le texte
en cas CHC c'est son c'est c'est son
choix c'est c'est à l'exécutif
c'est-à-dire à la première ministre ou
au chef de l'État de de le décider moi
j'essaie de travailler avec mes
collègues pour qu'on ait un résultat il
s'est passé des choses à haras c'est
tout frais il y a quelques semaines
c'était horrible c'était affreux il
s'est passé des dramesc il y a pas
longtemps quelques mois on en parle plus
mais c'est quand même dans les esprits
quelqu'un qui qui arrivait de de Suède
je crois et qui a poignardé des jeunes
enfants bon chaque fois on dit comment
ça a pu se faire on regarde la situation
bon il y a à chaque fois on dit ah benah
il y a un trou dans le filet il y a il y
a tel problème de toute façon on sait
très bien mais ça ça sera un débat qu'on
aura l'année prochaine que nous nous
essayons de trouver des solutions des
petits pas ici en France avec la
législation française c'est important
mais ce qui est encore plus important
c'est de trouver des solution à
l'échelle
européenne tant qu' tu auras pas de
règles européennne on peut s'excrimer
chez nous euh mais justement alors pour
éviter ça les républicains ils avaient
préparé une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui aurait dû être
examinée mardi soir mais qu'ils ont dû
retirer de l'ordre du jour faut d'accord
avec vous puisque vous n'étiez pas sur
la même ligne notamment sur
l'élargissement du référendum pour
permettre un référendum sur
l'immigration et sur la primauté du
droit national sur le droit européen
justement pour permettre un meilleur
contrôle de l'immigration sur le sol
national Bruno retaillot dit que le
texte n'est pas entéré est-ce que vous
travaillez avec eux sur un nouveau texte
non pour vous pour vous il doit être
entéré ce texte mais attends attendez ça
c'est la lettre au Père Noël je veux
dire Père Noël je voudrais un référendum
je voudrais des règles européennes
différentes et cetera
mais les conditions sont pas réunies
pour faire un référendum c'était
l'article 2 de cette PPLC il faut
élargir le champ de l'article 11 de la
Constitution bon l'affaire est enterrée
on en a parlé avec le chef de l'État à à
sa à Saint-Denis il y a quelques
quelques semaines la conclusion c'était
on on arrête le les débats il y a pas de
majorité possible donc stop ou les LR
n'était pas est-ce que là ils ont fait
une erreur de pas y aller pour défendre
encore moi jeis je suis pas un
psychiatre et donc ça ti de la
psychiatrie pour vous he mais je sais
pas je sais pas s'ils vont s'ils y vont
pas bon en tous les cas ceux qui étaient
là ont débattu
et à partir de
là la décision dans tous les cas ça a
été celle du chef de l'État et donc ça a
été une conclusion on on fait pas bon
donc ça sert à rien aujourd'hui de
refaire des PPLC en disant ah si si si
on va refaire on sait très bien que ça
marche pas et nous nous sommes hostiles
à l'élargissement de l'article 11 donc
ce référendum n'est pas possible sur
l'article 3 c'était l'identité
constitutionnelle de la France nous nous
sommes attachés à la hiérarchie euh des
normes juridiques européennes je dis pas
qu'il y a que du bonheur hein dans les
dans les choix de de l'Europe dans les
décisions juridictionnelles il faut y
travailler mais en tous les cas c'est
euh une situation qui prévaut donc on
était hostile on a essayit de trouver
des solutions ça marchait pas donc on a
procédé en commission des lois à un avec
un amendement de d'annulation de ce cet
article qui a été approuvé par la
commission des lois donc à partir de là
je pense que les conditions étant pas
réunis pour ce débat le président du
groupe LR a préféré retirer le texte ça
va laisser des traces dans la majorité
sénatoriale non par que des textes qui
qui viont qui viennent il y en a un
paquet quand même la majorité
sénatoriale fonctionne bien toujours oui
oui bien sûr bien sûr il y a un groupe l
il y a un groupe Union centriste et il y
a un président Gérard Larcher et alors
c'est comme dans dans tous les couples
il peut y avoir des hauts et des bas
mais vous restez en couple c'est ce que
vous nous dites bah oui on va parler
d'un d'un a texte un texte qui a été
présenté par le gouvernement mardi en
conseil des ministres sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG le
gouvernement qui finalement n'a pas
retenu exactement la formulation du
Sénat qui parlait de liberté conditions
dans lesquelles s'exerce la liberté de
la femme de mettre fin à sa grossesse le
gouvernement a rajouté liberté garantie
à la femme d'avoir un recours à une
interruption volontaire de grossesse
est-ce que avec ce changement de formule
vous voerez ce
texte moi je à titre personnel je je ne
suis pas favorable à cette inscription
dans dans la Constitution
pourquoi parce que pas plus que on vient
de parler du du référendum pour la
constitution l'élargissement de l'
article 11 parce que la Constitution
c'est quelque chose qui doit pas
beaucoup bouger on voit bien la
Constitution américaine elle a quasiment
pas bougé de depuis l'origine euh c'est
quelque chose qui qui est important si
on commence à tous les matins vouloir
ajouter quelque chose dans dans la dans
la Constitution il y a peu c'était pour
l'environnement après c'est maintenant
pour
lesvg on peut commencer à
constitutionnaliser euh toutes sortes de
sujets qu'on considère à tort ou à
raison comme important et après c'est
plus une
constitution ça
devient quelque chose de différent donc
voilà moi je respecte les choix des uns
et des autres cette affaire elle vient
du fait que les les États-Unis avaient
eu rencontré un problème avec la Cour
constitutionnelle aussitôt on a
transposé ça en France moi je crois là
encore qu'il serait beaucoup plus
judicieux de d'essayer d'introduire ces
notion là dans les chartes européennes
parce qu'il y a des pays où l'g en
Europe est soit menacé
soit pas garanti mais c'était passé de
justesse au Sénat la dernière fois
est-ce que vous pensez que là ça passera
écoutez j'ai pas euh commencer à en
parler avec mes collègues et regarder un
peu le fond de l'affaire
euh je pense qu'il y a des chances pour
que ça passe avec les voix de la gauche
à l'Assemblée nationale bien sûr mais
aussi au Sénat bon c'est un problème de
conscience et et chacun agira en liberté
en tous les cas dans mon groupe euh
bon si si ça devait passer bon c'est
comme ça Act doncte mais je pense pas
que ça soit l'essentiel parce que dans
dans notre
pays voilà je considère que l'IVG n'est
pas menacé semble-til garanti ce que
vous dites vous parlez beaucoup de
d'Europe depuis depuis le début de cette
cette émission ça me permet de vous
poser la la question de savoir si vous
avez évolué dans l'idée d'une liste
commune avec la majorité présidentielle
pour les européennes
non pour l'instant on est loin de tout
ça simplement moi j'ai évoqué j'ai
évoqué des des analyses que chacun peut
faire on est dans dans un pays où
politiquement qu'on le veuille ou non
euh il existe une forme de tripartition
de la vie politique française et qui se
polarise on le voit bien à travers les
études d'opinion on voit bien que il y a
pas de gauche sans monsieur Mélanchon
c'est triste mais c'est comme ça hein
moi je combats violemment Monsieur
Mélenchon enfin force de constater qu'il
polarise autour de lui euh au moins 15 %
de l'opinion et qu' il y a pas de gauche
sans lui euh on voit bien que sur la
droite la la plus à droite Jordane
Bardella et Marine Le Pen Polaris euh
avec accessoirement le courant de
Monsieur Zemour monsieur dupontignan et
cetera puis il y a ce qu'on appelle un
bloc central et il y a pas beaucoup
d'espace entre ce bloc central et les
extrêmes et à partir de là on voit très
bien que se dessine un chemin pour
Madame Le Pen en
2027 donc pour tous ceux qui ne veulent
pas de de ce résultat en 2027 la la
conclusion c'est qu'il faut réfléchir à
l'organisation de la vie politique entre
maintenant et 2027 pour savoir comment
ça marche je nous disent qu'aujourd'hui
les LR ont plus de place pour une
existence propre j'en sais rien c'est
les électeurs qui le diront en tous les
cas je je vois peu d'espace politique si
vous regardez les les sondages on voit
bien ce que ça a donné au présidentiel
et mais mais j'ai des amis beaucoup
d'amis chez les chez les républicain
mais les républicains ont fait un choix
qui est celui de
se de travailler à une ligne de droite
c'est plus la droite et le centre c'est
la droite et d'ailleurs ils ont lancé
les états généraux de la droite ils ont
choisi le candidat à la présidentielle
uniquement entre eux avec les adhérents
du de LR donc c'est une formation mais
vous l'avez soutenu après Valérie PCR là
ça veut dire que là vous vous pour les
européennes vous tournerez du côté de
majorité présiden il a un moment donné
où quand vous travaillez avec des gens
qui disent bah nous on est entre nous on
reste entre nous on travaille sur une
ligne qui est la nôtre et cetera et
cetera bon euh on se demande ce qu'on
fait là donc à un moment donné on est
bien obligé de tirer des des
conséquences donc on va réfléchir
travailler et puis décider et vous avez
commencé à travailler avec eux déjà ou
pas encore avec qui avec la majorité
présidenti non pas du tout non non de
toute façon attendez c'est au mois de
juin hein les européennes oui mais c'est
maintenant que les les listes
constituent
plein de confrèr déjà qui s'attaquent
aux européennes parce qu'il faut bien
organiser mais vous c'est la ligne que
vous souhaitez c'est faire une alliance
avec la major une analyse j'observe
j'observe la situation je suis bien
obligé de tirer des conséquences il y
aura des conséquences sur la majorité
sénatoriale si vous faites le choix
d'aller avec on travaille très bien
encore une fois entre nous
ici mais en tous les cas il y a une
préoccupation merci HERV Marseille merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité Julien
la une de la voie du Nord c'est la pluie
les pluies oui tout à fait PL record les
nables souterraines font le plein plein
à dire plus
facileécr de votre journal merci
julienciller merci à très vite merci
Marseille on passe au club des territoir